[Música]
disciplina paciencia
placer disciplina paciencia recuerda
bien estas tres palabras porque son los
tres ingredientes que necesitas para al
final te lo preguntaré
10 de marzo de 2020 yo estaba en el
teatro romea haciendo cobertura una obra
con clara segura era un éxito iba todo
de madre y de pronto pasa lo que
pasa llega al este de la
china y nos jode a todos
me escapo a cadaqués
y me confío en cadaqués con mi abuela mi
tía mi hermana mi novia
mi perra y mi hermano suerte que había
mi hermano porque si no era un
matriarcado que me hubiera invadido
felices los primeros días pero muy
contradictorios porque de pronto ni
manera de expresarme mi profesión mi
éxito se fue al garete y estaba en el
limbo en una casa fantástica en cadaqués
pero sin poder hacer lo que más me
gustaba que era hacer reír y trabajar
pues qué hago y empiezo a hacer vídeos
como un demente
como un demente y utilizo mis canales
instagram y youtube rescató a un
personaje jacobo que era un personaje
que lo tenía enterrado desde hacía años
incluso yo le había dado muerte
prácticamente había dicho yo no haré más
de jacobo porque ya lo he hecho muchos
años ya está hay que seguir y lo rescató
y mi hermano que tiene 30 años y que es
científico y que siempre tiene razón me
dijo si es el momento de hacer un jacobo
y me invento que jacobo está confinado
en baqueira
solo con su madre y hago un vídeo en la
cama de mi abuela que mi abuela tiene
una cama en cada que es que es como
isabelina una cama de estas que podría
salir en la serie de crown una cama muy
elegante verdad muy señorial y me pongo
ahí en la cama esa que parecería una
cama de que tendría la madre de jacobo
en baqueira y me hago un vídeo selphy y
le digo a mi novia cuando diga chuli
enfocas el foco y cuando llega a chuli
dámelo tal pues me ayudas y está todo
súper casero ese vídeo lo cuelgo el día
15 de marzo así nada dos días que
llevamos confinados lo cuelgo a las 4 de
la tarde y a las nueve de la noche
empiezo a recibir ese vídeo que había
colgado en youtube lo empiezo a recibir
por whatsapp ya fuera de youtube que ya
sabía
entonces me puse muy nervioso porque
dije
he hecho un viral el primer vídeo que
hago ya es un viral
entonces dije no puede ser que este hijo
de de jacobo tenga tanto éxito
empecé a separar el bruno actor que hace
de jacobo del bruno creador que tiene
que parir una serie que es jacobo
confinado en baqueira dije este video ha
sido viral por lo tanto todos a partir
de ahora van a tener menos
visualizaciones porque es y superar un
vídeo viral que ya circula por whatsapp
entonces el bruno creador empezó a
tenerle celos a jacobo y empezó a crear
otra serie para hacerle la competencia a
jacobo que fue confinados por el mundo
me inventé que un italiano en nápoles un
argentino en buenos aires- un japonés en
tokio un inglés en londres un francés en
francia y un loco catalán en cadaqués
conectaban por zoom y expresaban su
malestar y sus inquietudes sin conocerse
y un madrileño en malasaña absolutamente
un un barman porque pensé que
madrileño debe estar sufriendo más el
que tiene un bar y como todos los
madrileños tienen bares pues
me inventé amador que es un punky de
malasaña al que le tengo mucho cariño y
que le metía y también en el chat
empecé a escribir esa serie mi novia que
es maquilladora de polònia y crackòvia
empezó a ayudarme con la caracterización
hicimos kazuki que era el japonés super
currado hicimos al inglés
que había tomado mucho el sol
amador con los ojos pintados punky
empezamos a currar nos lo de verdad y yo
empecé a curarme más el guión y empezar
a hacer de creador pero también de
productor también de compositor porque
las músicas en youtube ya sabéis que la
autoría es complicado yo iba al piano y
grababa empecé a crear la serie con
ayuda de un chico que realizaba mis
vídeos en gerona claudia y yo un equipo
de 3
paralelamente iba haciendo gas de jacobo
el cabrón seguía triunfando y las
visualizaciones de confinados por el
mundo iban bien pero nada comparado con
el de jacobo
que se volvió a finalizar y el jacobo
confinado en baqueira 3 también se
viralizó y volvió a circular por
whatsapp y el 5 otra vez o sea
hizo como tres o cuatro virales jacob
y empecé a tener no solo celos sino
rabia ya deja del personaje de jacob o
de lo bien que funcionaba y a la vez
cuando escribía el guión de jacobo
pensaba venga voy a decir una barbaridad
más bestia para qué y a éste lo el
que más y venga me voy a en su
madre y tal y aprovechaba jacobo
como para cagarme en la madre que
era lo que sentíamos todo lo que
teníamos ganas de cargarnos en la punta
que nos parió con perdón
paralelamente me pasó una cosa que fue
el mejor regalo que me ha dado este año
y esta pandemia y es que en instagram
empecé a hacer unas cápsulas unos vídeos
en los que por primera vez en la vida yo
no hacía ningún personaje yo era
yo siempre he sido
aunque no lo parezca muy tímido y me ha
dado mucho miedo exponerme exponer mi
persona por eso siempre he hecho person
a grandes actrices y grandes
una entrevista en la
pero empecé a hacer unos vídeos en
instagram en instagram tv en los que
hablaba de la actualidad y en los que
opinaba ostras ahora esta ley ostras
ahora el 'toque de queda' etcétera
etcétera y recuerdo que en mayo hice un
vídeo que se llamaba la fase 05
porque os acordáis que de pronto dijeron
la fase 0 y en barcelona la fase 05
porque en barcelona siempre somos los
más puteados de todos season es todo el
mundo y barcelona los mas puteados ahí
te aplastan si eres de barcelona por
haber nacido y te hacen ir a 30 por hora
las calles ahí
porque eres de barcelona más lento y
bueno pues entonces me acuerdo que hizo
ese vídeo diciendo la fase 05 o sea qué
de números el 0 5 o sea que
de fases esa sea porque tenemos
que decir que los de barcelona estaremos
en la fase 05 prefiero sacar un 0 y lo
compare con un examen tú si sacas un 0 o
si es una nota digna
que saca un cero tío es que no se puede
hacer peor
en cambio si sacas un cero y medio es
del loser
es de loser saca un cero para sacar un
cero y medio y dije es como si te dan
y dices no dame con rúcula
la rúcula es indiscutiblemente asquerosa
ya sé que la tomamos pero es asquerosa
no no me des la con rúcula no me
maquillo es la dame rúcula digo
dame
pero döring
ese vídeo en el que hablaba de la fase
05 conectó con la gente y se viralizó y
yo recuerdo que estaba en cadaqués y mi
tía mi hermano me iban diciendo tú te
das cuenta que me están
enviando tu vídeo gente
los primos de madrid círculo
en cataluña pero de pronto ese vídeo
empezó hace
para mí fue como decir wow qué miedo sea
este soy yo aquí no está jacobo no está
no hay maquillaje este soy yo opinando
sobre lo que no
para mí eso fue un salto al vacío y lo
sigo sufriendo porque a partir de ese
vídeo ya no pude dejar
ese perfil yo ya no lo pude abandonar ya
demasiado tarde
seguir con esos vídeos porque en el
fondo los disfrutaba mucho plata
tuve que seguir disciplina porque cuando
algo te funciona tienes que ser
disciplinado
y sobre todo lo que no puedes es
precipitar las cosas si has tenido un
viral no puedes esperar que los
siguientes sean virales la ciencia
habla de lo que
realmente te apetezca no tienes por qué
hacer uno al día puedes hacer uno a la
semana o incluso uno cada 15 días es
mejor hacer una pieza buena cada 15 días
que dos o tres mediocres
pero realmente
creador
se abre para mí una puerta muy
grande porque
muy sencilla no me tengo que maquillar
sencillamente tengo que pensar qué es lo
que quiero contar y lo cuento
con un plano fijo
me preparo el monólogo lo escribo los
me encanta escribir la gente me dice
como improvisas estos vídeos no hay nada
improvisado está todo escrito con
no solo está escrito sino que lo escribo
y a veces lo dejó dormir reposar una
noche algo que os aconsejo muchísimo es
fundamental que dejéis reposar porque
buenos platos siempre se cocinan a fuego
lento
al día siguiente vas a leer eso y vas a
decir esto está mal esto es largo
por tanto como creador empecé a decir
ostras es
esta especie de género de monólogos si
queréis pero no de monólogo de club de
la comedia sino de charla contigo de
habéis visto lo que
segundo vídeo que se viralizó fue el del
tic de queda
y es un tic que ha venido para quedarse
ese vídeo hizo 700 mil en instagram más
o menos y circuló por whatsapp lo cual
da mucha rabia porque ya no sabes cuánta
gente lo ve realmente pero bueno
me llamaron de la ventana de láser me
llamo carlos franz y no queremos hablar
de tu vídeo de pronto yo estaba hablando
la radio a nivel nacional de un vídeo
que había colgado yo haciendo un chiste
del ticket de queda y diciendo que nos
teníamos que inventar una droga nueva
pero una droga buena sea una droga
realmente flipante
con tanto con el toque de queda con la
mascarilla con tanta con tanto que
estábamos viviendo esperan septiembre ya
una droga de estas que les dan a los
astros que van a la nasa
y dije porque los astronautas pasan de
la nasa digo del espacio a la tierra que
es como pasar de roma' albacete
y uno de albacete ese cabreo bueno me
dijo cómo puedes comparar al vacío sea
como
has estado alguna vez en albacete yo
pensé sí
y es muy feo no pasa nada
no pasa nada
esto se cuelga en youtube
da igual
esa puerta que aquí
me llevo algunos disgustos porque
evidentemente cuando cuelgas un vídeo
así en el que hablas de la actualidad y
criticas ciertas cosas como por cuando
miguel bosé organiza
[Música]
y me metí con él y me metí con el hecho
de negar la pandemia ya esas alturas que
dices chico haberlo negado en abril qué
a todo el mundo
todo el mundo ha perdido a alguien es un
poco tarde pero da igual tú digas lo que
digas tendrás a haters ahí o tendrás a
gente diciendo
no te has informado te trae 30 y mi
hermano que es científico contestando y
diciéndole a él
a mí me sigue
produciendo una sensación de violencia y
de agresión
el hecho de ver ciertos comentarios en
mis redes
ergo no lo sé
pero mi madre sí
con mi novia o mi hermano y entonces a
veces ellos contestan pero yo no los leo
porque
soy más feliz entonces cuando cuelga un
vídeo tengo la sensación de lanzar como
una especie de bomba depende del tema no
es yo no me considero tampoco un crítico
social ni un periodista
sencillamente expreso mi punto de vista
pero sí que nos negaré que
lo suelto allí dijo y bueno pues
hasta que llegó el vídeo de no somos
cuando en las
en realidad el govern permitió ir a los
mítines cuando
uno de tarrasa no podía irme a ver al
teatro a barcelona o ni siquiera uno del
hospital estos era confinamiento
municipal y de pronto el joven dijo no
pero los mítines si podéis pues eso me
indignó y con ese vídeo que es el primer
vídeo en el que yo oficialmente estoy
y en el que oficialmente no
escribí ningún gag porque yo como ahí
era más bruno que nunca y dije se acabó
se acabó voy a decir lo que pienso y ese
vídeo hizo un millón seiscientos mil
visualizaciones de instagram y es el
vídeo más visto porque es así que
madrid- todo el mundo habla de tu vídeo
también por qué
indirectamente no directamente criticaba
al govern y eso les encanta claro
entonces había un cierto morbo no es que
has visto a bruno está dice no
somos se nos mean encima
bueno es la sensación que yo tenía y lo
dije vale y mucha gente con
en ese momento se nos estaban mirando
encima al menos a las actrices y a los
actores que intentábamos hacer teatro
ni siquiera uno que estaba al lado
ir a ver a un gran político un gran
mitin esos grandes espectáculos que son
los mítines
todo este rollo de 15 minutos dios mío
que han volado
para deciros
para que se abran puertas hay que
cerrarlas
yo dejé polonia que era un programa que
me estaba dando muchísimo reconocimiento
y muchísimo
porque yo ya me había convertido en el
presidente
al presidente
y yo llevaba 11 años siendo
en el momento político que eso
representaba en la ducha en pelotas la
gente me preguntaba qué presidente sería
independiente
comprenderéis que al final pensé si sigo
voy a ser el presidente de la vida dejé
polonia porque estaba muy desgastado y
porque para que se abrieran puertas
tenía que cerrar esa y la tenía que
hacer
para siempre
muy bien que te vayan las cosas
si no hay placer no vas adelante el
placer es lo que nos tiene que mover
siempre
yo en este año de pandemia
me sorprendió a mí mismo estos vídeos
que hice yo no los había calculado yo
estaba en el teatro la mar de tranquilo
y de pronto me encerraron en una casa en
cadaqués y yo tenía que hacer algo con
mi hiperactividad y con
mi imbecilidad
entonces empecé a hacer vídeos como un
maníaco pero esos vídeos me empezaron a
llevar por territorio es que yo no
conocía
una caja de truenos
no sabéis lo que tenéis dentro no los
equivocados equivocaron mucho
porque de ahí del fracaso de equivocarse
de equivocarse saldrán cosas
maravillosas pero que os mueva el placer
las ganas la ilusión que os haga sonreír
lo que hacéis porque si no no habrá
manera siempre es las cosas siguiendo un
patrón porque esto es lo que triunfa
esto es lo que
paciencia la paciencia es fundamental
porque en mi profesión si no tienes
paciencia te ahogas mi carrera
y la mayoría de carreras pero
resistencia no es de velocidad no llega
al que corre más llega el que aguanta
más las hostias que te van dando
creedme que yo
las triunfado
yo habré triunfado cuando sea feliz
cuando tenga la felicidad personal y ser
feliz es una quimera es muy difícil
profesionalmente hago lo que quiero eso
sí que es
si no me divierto yo me rindo me
supone un reto lo que yo tengo que hacer
ya no lo hago
placer
paciencia y disciplina
disciplina hay que ser un poco japoneses
también tenemos la parte mediterránea
divertida que nos gustan mucho las
cervezas y el vino y reírnos y bailar
pero nos falta esa cosa nipona de hay
que trabajar
porque somos muy de mañana abusos
[Música]
hay que ponerse
si te pones en algo que te gusta
entonces es la monda pero hay que tener
disciplina y cuando encuentras el camino
ahí como un toro
placer disciplina y paciencia son los 3